a devastating fire it happened in
downtown las vegas over the weekend
leaves many looking for a new place to
live and city leaders are letting them
know we are here for you several
buildings and some two dozen cars were
destroyed in that fire near fremont and
eastern sally jaramillo joins us now
live from there with the efforts to help
those find a new place to live sally
brian and denise the red cross along
with councilwoman olivia diaz want the
community to know that they're only one
phone call away fire crews were out here
earlier looking for clues on who or what
could have started this
we know that you know it's going to be a
while before we recover and we can
rebuild councilwoman olivia diaz is
devastated by the fire but relieved no
lives were lost the city along with the
red cross are making sure everyone
affected gets help so we haven't seen
nearly as many residents as we would
have assumed that we would have so
that's why we're really encouraging
those who haven't checked in with us to
just
make that phone call marcus laner who
has lived at the freeman urban town home
lobs for almost three years is grateful
for the assistance my wife and i and a
friend of ours we were out at a bar
having a good time and uh our neighbor
had called us and let us know that the
neighborhood was on fire i had to like
stop like what he's like the
neighborhood's on fire and i had my dogs
inside the house and he has a key to my
house so i immediately was like bro if
it's safe for you to do it go to my
house and just grab my dogs that's all i
care about right now laner says his
truck was destroyed in the fire
it's heartbreaking it really is
a lot of these people lost a lot and i
hope that they're getting the help that
they need and as we get ready to
celebrate the fourth of july diaz
message i just really really would like
all of our families to make sure that
their fire alarms are up to date that
the batteries are installed properly
that if they're older than 10 years
they're switched out be smart about
fireworks this year and just be safe you
know keep your family safe
back out live tim samanski with las
vegas fire and rescue tells me they will
be back here tomorrow morning with an
arson dog to further investigate all of
this for now reporting live from
downtown sally caramillo live local now